this is a 2d version of my 3d video
about DNA structure if you have a Google
cardboard or VR headset mosey on over to
the video description and find the link
to the 3d version it's worth it I
promise but if you're ready to learn
about DNA and 2d let's begin
deoxyribonucleic acid or DNA is an
absolutely incredible molecule the
arrangement of its subunits codes nearly
all of the genetic information that
makes you well you most of your DNA is
located in the nucleus of the cell and
when it is time DNA makes every protein
and enzyme in your body and zaimes in
turn synthesize all of the biological
molecules you need to make on your own
carbohydrates hormones RNA everything
that's necessary for your tissues and
organs to function here we're looking at
a small piece of DNA rotating in 3d
space we'll come back to the structure
but for now let's focus on a single
repeating unit of DNA which is called a
nucleotide the nucleotide is made up of
a phosphate group which carries a
negative 2 charge on the oxygen atoms a
2 deoxyribose sugar named this way
because this is carbon 2 of the sugar
and it does not have an OHA OOP finally
we have a nitrogenous base here in DNA
there are four common bases this
nucleotide is cited in mono phosphate if
we remove the phosphate group this
fragment is referred to as a nucleoside
and this one is called site adine to
remember the difference between
nucleotides and nucleosides I use this
mnemonic device a nucleotide is the
total fragment and the nucleoside with
an S contains only the sugar which
begins with s if we simplify this
structure even further we can focus in
on the base pair and see what makes the
four bases unique the bases are called
nitrogenous bases because they all
contain nitrogen atoms
their rings this nitrogenous base is the
molecule cytosine and is a pyramidal
ring perimeters are six-membered
heterocycle z-- with nitrogen atoms at
the 1 and 3 positions of the ring
cytosine has an amine group and a
carbonyl group this C double bond o
coming off of the perimeter ring two of
the nitrogenous bases are perimeters and
thymine is the other one I mean differs
from cytosine because it contains two
carbonyl groups an extra ch3 and a
different arrangement of the double
bonds within and around the ring the
other nitrogenous bases are purine rings
this one is adenine purines contain a
six membered ring fused to a five
membered ring with four nitrogen atoms
within the rings in this arrangement
adenine is characterized by an amine
group attached to the ring the final
base we need to know is guanine the nh-2
group of adenine is replaced by a
carbonyl and there's an nh-2 group at
this position which was unsubstituted in
adenine because DNA is so long and made
up of so many nucleotides it is common
to abbreviate the base pairs as the
first letter of their name so the
perimeters are C and T and the purines
are a and G we had to look closely at
the structures of the bases because they
are key in holding the DNA double helix
together which we're looking at now the
orientation of the nitrogen oxygen and
hydrogen atoms allows hydrogen bonding
to occur between the strands and this is
why DNA exists as a double helix the
perimeter T pairs up with the purine a
making two hydrogen bonds between the
base pairs this one from the NH to
another nitrogen atom and this one from
the carbonyl outside the ring to the
hydrogen atom of this amine the other
pairing occurs between the pyramidal C
and the purine G
the hydrogen bonding is similar however
there's an extra amine carbonyl hydrogen
bond the three hydrogen bonds that hold
G and C together add extra stability to
the double helix and DNA that is rich in
G and C base pairs comes apart at the
hydrogen bonds or melts at a higher
temperature experimentally the sugars
and phosphate groups bond covalently to
make up the backbone of the DNA molecule
and we can see the alternating units
here phosphate sugar phosphate sugar the
two paired strands do not run in the
same direction they actually run anti
parallel or in opposite directions we
can see this by looking at the sugars
associated with a single base pair
notice how the oxygen atom points upward
here but points downward on this side
each terminus of the DNA strand can be
labeled as either 3 prime or 5 prime and
this depends on the direction that the
sugar is facing the numbering of the
sugar carbon atoms begins where the
sugar attaches to the nitrogenous base
now we can count the carbon atoms in the
order that they are connected 1 2 3 4 5
since this terminal o H group is on the
fifth carbon of the sugar this is a 5
prime end let's wind around the DNA
strand so that we can look at the other
end of that same strand
notice the O H group here is on the 1 2
3 third carbon atom this is the 3 prime
end of that same strand now let's
retrace our steps zooming back up to
that 5 prime end that we first looked at
and now we're going to move over to its
complementary strand that it's hydrogen
bonded to the Frio h group here
is that the one two three third carbon
atom so this is another three prime end
in order to make new cells to grow or
replace dead cells the entire strand of
DNA needs to be copied to do this the
double helix is unzip by enzymes and an
exact copy of each strand of DNA is made
before the cell divides up with perfect
copies of the genetic material in each
cell what we're looking at now is DNA
being unzipped by an enzyme called a
helicase
notice how the unwound strand of DNA has
held apart from its complementary strand
by being buried into the interior of the
enzyme this structure was actually not
captured using protein crystallography
it was done using a technique called
cryo-electron microscopy and the
pioneers of this technique won the Nobel
Prize for cryo-em
in 2017 if you unwound all of the DNA in
your cell and lined it up end to end it
would be about two meters long
considering the fact that each
nucleotide is only about 60 nanometers
much smaller than even the wavelength of
light these are extremely long chains of
nucleotides in order to package the DNA
strands to fit into the nucleus of your
cells proteins called histones whine the
DNA around themselves in what is called
a nucleosome scientists have been able
to capture crystal structures of parts
of these nucleus home complexes and
that's what we're looking at right now
notice the way the DNA becomes wrapped
around these proteins in such an orderly
fashion so amazing i truly hope you
enjoyed stepping inside of DNA if you
want to take more macro molecular
journeys with me please like this video
and subscribe to my channel